[Music]
on this thursday night an unprecedented
postponement in canada
the pandemic delays newfoundland and
labrador's election
no one could have predicted where we
would be today a surge in covid cases
splits the vote
who casts their ballot this weekend and
who has to wait
manitoba's deal to buy a canadian-made
vaccine the province runs out of
patience
as doses run short snowbirds flocking to
florida
they're all over yeah oh yeah the
canadians defying travel warnings
plus finding strength through song don't
you
cry opera singers helping covet
survivors
catch their breath
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
for the first time in this pandemic an
election in canada is being derailed by
covet 19.
newfoundland and labrador which had kept
case counts low for
almost a year is in the midst of a
rapidly escalating outbreak and now the
provincial election set for saturday
has been postponed but only for half the
province
people living in and around the st
john's region where case numbers are
surging
will have to wait to vote in person the
case count keeps
rising there a record-breaking 100 new
positive coveted cases were reported
today
there are now 210 active cases that's
the highest number
in newfoundland and labrador since the
pandemic began
the province's chief electoral officer
says the situation is too volatile to
allow the full election to go ahead
the leader of the pc party calls it an
affront to democracy that creates
two classes of voters he wants voting
postponed across the entire province
ross lord has our top story tonight
compounding the dread of a midwinter
election with a sudden outbreak of
covert 19
is a no win situation especially for
newfoundland
and labrador premier andrew fury his
plan to boost the liberal minority
government into a majority by calling an
early election
has backfired the decision was mine the
problems
no one could have predicted where we
were it would be today we're pretty well
locked down right now
despite another day of record cases the
chief electoral officer has decided 22
of 40 ridings will
still vote this saturday but bruce chalk
has postponed in-person voting
for the other 18 ridings most of them in
saint john's and surrounding communities
where the outbreak is centered in a
letter to party leaders
chalk noted electoral workers many
part-time and elderly
will not work in the current climate he
added
more individuals will choose their
personal health over working in the
election
and polls will not be able to open the
province's top doctor doesn't exactly
endorse the decision
mr choc made his decision based on i'm
sure uh quite a number of factors
and um you know it is what it is so
um you know i think that we
um if we can do the election this way
that's great
it takes a lot to postpone elections in
canada in 1997
historic floods from the red river
devastated farmers
and put pressure on elections officials
to postpone voting
in parts of manitoba but they insisted
the vote go ahead as planned
covert 19 is a whole other story
in-person voting in the saint john's
area
won't happen until a later date people
can vote by mail-in ballot in the
meantime
but some voters say it's time to forget
about the election
i think they've got to push it back you
know we're talking months here
it should be the summer uh at the
earliest at the absolute earliest
it's unclear what all this dysfunction
means for who eventually wins
and whether andrew fury's election
gamble can still pay off
ross lord global news ontario's public
health experts warned today the threat
from the more contagious new variants
is real according to a top coveted 19
advisor variants now account for between
5
and 10 percent of all cases in ontario
because it's about 50 percent more
contagious the uk variant could dominate
new cases in ontario within weeks
if strict public health measures aren't
followed now the consequences
could be devastating but there's little
room for
error in our response to this threat we
face the very real risk of a third wave
and potentially a third lockdown there
will be little time to react quickly
because of how fast the variant spread
here's the potential impact on ontario's
intensive care units because the
variants spread so fast icu cases could
begin to surge by mid-march
most people who end up in the icu are
not in long-term care so
the vaccinations underway now will do
little to help
what's happening in north bay ontario is
a red flag for what could be coming
an outbreak in an apartment building
there has grown out of 24 cases at least
18 are now
confirmed to be a variant of concern
testing is still being done to determine
which one a person who lives in the
building and had traveled
internationally first tested positive
on february 2nd to try to limit people
moving around
march break in ontario has now been
postponed until april 12th
the education minister says the decision
was made in part
to discourage travel and prevent people
from gathering
outside their households we recognize
the congregation is a key driver of the
spread of covet 19
something we realized over the winter
break and we will not take that risk
again
students in ontario are only now
beginning to return to classrooms they
switch to remote learning because of a
spike in cases after
christmas manitoba's premier is making
his own deal to buy vaccines separate
from the federal government
and it's a vaccine that if all goes as
planned will be made in canada
clinical trials are only just beginning
so it's not something that will happen
soon but as abigail beeman reports it
looks like other provinces
are planning to follow suit canada first
is in danger
of becoming canada last frustrated by a
slow vaccine rollout manitoba is going
it alone
buying 2 million doses from providence
therapeutics a canadian-made
mrna vaccine that's only in early
clinical trials
and unlike the federal government the
premier promises to release details of
the contract
once finalized i have written to every
premier
telling them about today's announcement
and inviting them to partner
with the company of their choice that
may be available
to assist us in building a canadian made
solution while he said ottawa wouldn't
take his call the ceo of providence
therapeutics says
other premiers are already calling him
though he won't say which
ones he plans to lock down domestic
orders for this year
by early next week hopeful for health
canada approval
in the fall we fully expect that the
provinces that have placed orders with
us will have vaccines
you know in their freezers waiting and
as soon as that
that approval comes they'll be able to
roll them out there's always uh it's
economies of scaling that
there's it's always uh in some ways
better uh for a quote that uh sort of
the government of canada you know as a
bulk
sort of buyer on behalf of canada and
the problems of territories
as for how those bulk agreements are
going 2.4
of canadians have received at least one
dose of vaccine
and 0.5 have received two doses we're
approaching something that we're calling
the big lift
uh which is the phase in which we go
from vaccine
scarcity as we are right now to
receiving millions upon millions next
week pfizer shipments will ramp up
officials gave new numbers for the next
four weeks with more than 400 000 doses
coming each round
there are new details about the next
modernist shipment too
we'll get a 168 000 doses the week of
february 22nd
another cut this time fewer than 70
percent
of what we were originally expecting
abigail beeman global news
ottawa there is confusion over the
federal requirement that travelers who
arrive in the country by air must
quarantine in a hotel for three days at
their own expense
the prime minister announced it two
weeks ago but the plan is not fully in
place yet the alberta government is
calling for more
transparency around the rules and as
heather urex west reports some who have
already stayed in government approved
hotels are
sharing what happened to them and now
i'm being held here
it is a rare look inside a federal
quarantine facility
one of eleven hotels being used across
canada
to quarantine travelers the public
health agency determines to be a risk
calgary's mitch bolu says he was taken
here in late january
following a work trip to florida the
place wasn't that like i'm not
complaining the fact that you know
whatever they put me in a hotel and i
had to stay there for three days like
that's fine
but beaulieu is taking issue with the
little information he was given about
why even though he had a negative covet
test
he was taken to the facility angelo
venegas has a similar complaint
he had a negative test result after a
recent trip to mexico
but he was taken to a facility because
he had family members with health issues
at home i was not like aware of that
specific because i have my own room i
have my own bathroom so like as long as
you
as long as you isolate yourself at home
i thought that it was not
going to be a big deal it's because of
this confusion that the alberta
government is asking
ottawa for clarity in a letter addressed
to public safety minister bill blair
and health minister patty haidu
alberta's health and justice ministers
right
the lack of clear communication has
created confusion
and fear about unlawful detention which
will erode canadians
trust in their governments as the
government of alberta we demand a clear
and definitive explanation from federal
officials
on the travel quarantine policy and how
it is applied
i think certainly more information and
clearer information
is always better and is always going to
be to be beneficial
the public health agency of canada says
travelers must present a negative cova
test
and a valid 14-day isolation plan
adding that further details will be
announced in the coming days
heather urex west global news calgary
bombardier is laying off more employees
the montreal-based company is cutting
600 jobs mostly office employees
and by the end of the year bombardier
says it will stop making lear jets the
private planes have been in service
since 1963.
bombardier has become a shadow of its
former self having gone from making
planes and trains of all shapes and
sizes to essentially
just business jets covet 19 is
dominating most headlines but in bc
deaths from drug overdoses
have reached a grim new milestone more
than 1700 people died
due to illicit drugs in 2020. that's the
most in any year
since the province declared a public
health emergency in 2016. more people
died of drug overdoses in 2020 than car
crashes
homicides suicides and prescription drug
related deaths
combined most deaths were caused by a
toxic illicit drug supply but officials
say
social isolation caused by that pandemic
made the situation
worse ontario's police watchdog has
confirmed a child who was killed during
a confrontation last november was
shot by the police a 33-year-old man and
his one-year-old son suffered gunshot
wounds during the interaction
the baby boy died at the scene his dad
died in the hospital nearly a week later
the special investigations unit says
three officers opened fire on the man
after his truck crashed into a cruiser
while police were laying down a spike
belt
they were investigating an alleged
kidnapping at the time
new details are emerging about
allegations involving canada's former
top soldier
last week global news revealed
allegations that general jonathan vance
behaved inappropriately with two female
subordinates
now we're learning of a third
investigation dating back six years
mercedes stevenson broke this story and
has more details tonight
mercedes donna global news has learned
the sensitive investigations unit of the
canadian forces military police
opened an investigation into allegations
of inappropriate behavior
by general jonathan vance in 2015. the
military says
those allegations centered on vance's
conduct while he served as deputy
commander of the allied
joint force command in naples italy a
position that he held from 2013 until
july of 2014.
sources tell global news the
investigation was into questions over
whether vance had an inappropriate
relationship
with an american jag officer who was his
subordinate in naples
that officer is now his wife in a
statement the department of national
defense told global news
that the investigation did not meet the
elements of the offense
to lay charges under the code of service
discipline or the criminal code of
canada
but investigators will not disclose what
their probe involved
including whether electronic
communications were reviewed
the force also did not disclose the
findings of the investigation
military sources have raised questions
about how robust the investigation was
including whether any potential
witnesses were interviewed
global news spoke exclusively to the
retired three-star general who succeeded
vance in naples
and who was in command at the time of
the investigation
retired lieutenant general mike day he
told global news
quote i was told there was an
investigation
but to the best of my knowledge nobody
in the canadian contingent in naples
was interviewed given that an
investigation is now reopened i think it
would be inappropriate for me to comment
further
this is now the third set of allegations
of inappropriate behavior made against
the former chief of the defense staff
vance has denied all allegations of
inappropriate behavior
he also says he was never in a
relationship with his now wife
while she was under his command and that
their relationship did not commence
until he returned to canada and she was
no longer under his command
donna mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks now to washington d.c and the
impeachment trial of former president
donald trump
during their final arguments the
democrats tried to cement their case
that the violent mob of trump supporters
that stormed the capitol
was acting and on his direction they
used the writer's own words as
evidence and as jackson proskow reports
democrats believe trump
could incite more violence if he's not
convicted
of the united states the words of the
trump supporters who stormed the capitol
i thought i was following my president i
thought i was following
what we were called to do were presented
to the impeachment trial as
evidence of his alleged incitement and
control of the mob
the president told them to be there
and so they actually believed they would
face
no punishment the final day of arguments
took senators through trump's history of
promoting political violence
from his early rallies to
charlottesville to january 6
and the days that followed i also want
you to know
that our incredible journey is only
just beginning and he was right
unless we take action the violence
is only just beginning democrats warned
of trump's lack of remorse and his
failure to correct his big lie about a
stolen election
he does not say the one sentence that
would stop
future political violence the election
was not stolen the jarring evidence
presented so far has stunned even those
who lived through that horrific day
the evidence that has been presented
thus far
is pretty damning president biden
suggests it may even sway some
republicans
my guess is some minds may have been
changed but i don't know
but likely not enough to convict trump
it would take 17
republicans joining with democrats that
would form the basis for barring trump
from running again
so if he gets back into office and it
happens again
we'll have no one to blame but ourselves
trump's defense is likely to focus on
his right to free speech and claims he
did not incite the mob
and for those who are uncomfortable with
trump's actions a constitutional
argument
that he cannot be impeached as a now
former president
democrats have now wrapped their
arguments and trump's defense team will
begin its presentation on
friday things are moving so fast that a
final vote could come as early as
saturday
which will all but certainly result in
trump's acquittal
donna okay jackson prosco in washington
thank you
the pandemic is not interfering with
everyone's travel plans coming up the
snowbirds who insist on flying south for
the winter
the canada u.s land border remains
closed to all non-essential travel but
that hasn't stopped some snow birds from
heading south for the winter our mike
armstrong was in the u.s covering
another story in florida and he talked
to some canadians who didn't want to
give up their winter in the sun
the third one down here on your left
that's a canadian
about half the owners in this mobile
home park are canadian snowbirds
there's three in a row right there
although when richard decker starts
pointing them out
hi jane it feels like even more so
they're all over yeah oh yeah
well this winter most of decker's
neighbors have stayed in the north
most oh but not all tons of people are
missing let's put it that way
len simmons is down from toronto he flew
to tennessee met his girlfriend and
drove the rest of the way with her
simmons figures 80 to 90 percent of the
other canadians in the park
didn't come down but says for him that
wasn't an
option i'm not staying up in the cold
weather i've been coming here for 30
years and i'm not staying up there in
the cold weather
no u.s state gets more canadian tourists
than florida
in a normal year about 4.1 million make
the trip down
this isn't a normal year the canucks
have come
disregarded the government's warnings we
both flew air canada
and in margaret johnston of newcastle
ontario's case
also ignored the pleadings of her sons
you sure you want to go mom
yes oh well stay safe mom don't do this
don't do that
one thing that's gotten harder to do for
snowbirds is to get vaccinated
florida has tightened the rules to cut
down on so-called vaccine tourism people
now have to show proof of residency
another issue is insurance and the
chance of catching covet 19 in the u.s
we've had canadians come down and they
have had it
a couple of days after they arrived we
tracked that couple down they're now
back home in nova scotia but after a mix
up with their insurance provider they're
now looking at a massive
300 000 bill it's a cautionary tale but
one that's still being ignored
by people who insist they can just take
precautions
when we go shopping it takes nerve
both women have their return flights
booked but with the canadian government
adding new rules
testing and quarantining their plans are
going to change
leaving florida and going home is
getting more complicated
and more expensive mike armstrong global
news
largo florida this little piggy
hit the arcade still ahead new research
into the intelligence of pigs
they call this an ice volcano it's in
southern kazakhstan and has caused a bit
of a tourism boom there it's about 14
meters tall it's caused by water from a
hot spring
spewing out and freezing causing a tower
of ice
a smaller one was spotted along lake
ontario this week formed by
waves under the ice and you know it's
cold when even
penguins aren't going outside that's the
case at the calgary zoo they canceled
the
penguin walk today saying the extreme
cold puts too much stress on the birds
it
dropped down to minus 27 degrees in
calgary today but it feels like minus 40
with the wind chill
the penguins don't go for their daily
winter wattle when temperatures
dip below minus 25 it's well established
pigs are smart they can use tools learn
how mirrors work and display sensitivity
to their peers
now there's proof they can play video
games in a study published in frontiers
in psychology researchers trained four
pigs to toggle an arcade-style joystick
with their snouts
the pigs understood the connection
between the stick and the game
researchers say that is no small feat
they kept at it even after the dispenser
that rewarded them with food
broke researchers gave them verbal
encouragement and they moved to higher
game levels
the lead author who's been researching
this for decades says this confirms
how we interact with pigs and what we do
them to them impacts
and matters to them
[Music]
we take for granted the ability to
breathe until a deadly virus quite
literally takes people's breath away
even some people who recover from the
worst of covid19 have debilitating
damage to their lungs
now the english national opera has come
up with a program using singing
exercises
to help crystal commansing explains
sing just say it with me sing
warm-up routines vocal stretches
breathing exercises
they're all tools that help singers
engage their bodies
singing specialist susie zumpa has taken
her expertise from the stage
to her living room
everyone in this training session is a
covid19
survivor struggling with breathlessness
even singing simple songs proved helpful
for this group
people when they come to this are
often feeling so desperate
and have been managing things that feel
really difficult for a very long time
eno breathe is expanding across england
it's estimated there are around
three hundred thousand long covet
patients in need of help
and that's just in the uk i can't
satisfy
my lungs like i need that big gulp
there right now it's been 11 months
since elaine
dirk was infected st
paul's hospital in bc was the first in
canada
to set up a coped 19 clinic
investigating the
ongoing health challenges of survivors
but there's nothing like eno breathe
in two three four what makes it
different what makes it unique is the
fact that you're being told
um the benefits of it and you're
experiencing the benefits of it
being able to use skills and expertise
in other in new and different ways that
can have
direct impact and positive impact and
benefit for patients
at the moment is hugely rewarding
knowing the benefits
jenny mulica says international
expansion
is possible giving hope to those
like dirk i'd be willing to try anything
to get myself
back to where i was the eno breathe team
stresses being able to carry a tune
doesn't matter the focus is on feeling
better
rest your head breathing
deep crystal gomanson global news
london and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's euro canada is a shot of cold
and
sunny calgary please email your canada
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching robin gill will be
here tomorrow i'm back on saturday with
the new reality and a look
at the variants and whether we're in the
calm before the storm
take care of yourselves bye-bye